[Musique]
bonjour Mounir Satouri et bienvenue au
bistro du théâre Montini je vous en prie
mer merci venez vous installer vous êtes
le le premier élu Europe Écologie Les
Verts à participer à cette émission il y
en a il faut le dire hein assez peu dans
le département les dernières élections
ont été compliquées pour toute la gauche
et donc également pour votre formation
même si la rupture avec le PS pour vous
aujourd'hui est plutôt consommée on va y
revenir au cours de la prochaine
demi-heure on va parler de vous de vos
engagements vous êtes conseiller
régional conseiller municipal au Murau
dans les deux assemblées vous siégez
dans dans l'opposition et puis au cours
de cette première séquence on va revenir
sur quelquesuns des sujets d'actualité
l'un des sujet qui focalise l'attention
de tous les élus de tous les politiques
c'est le vote du Royaume-Uni avec le
fameux brexit qui a été décidé les
électeurs se sont prononcés pour une
sortie de l'Union européenne Europe
Écologie Les les Verts appelle à un
nouveau projet il faut revoir les
traités concrètement comment ça peut
s'organiser et sur quelle base il faut
repartir reconstruire selon vous d'abord
moi j'interprète ce vote comme le vote
de ceux qui ont peur face à une Europe
qui malheureusement arrêté d'avancer et
donc la seule manière pour nous de
maintenir cette belle idée qui est
l'Europe c'est une refondation en
profondeur l'Europe elle s'est éloignée
des citoyens l'Europe est devenue aux
yeux de beaucoup d'Européens comme une
structure lointaine technocratique et
qui s'occupe pas du quotidien et si on
veut
conserver cette belle acqui qui est
l'Europe ben il faut construire une
Europe plus proche des gens qui protège
qui fait en sorte que les acquis sociaux
sont préservés qui protègeent
l'environnement et qui surtout permet de
dessiner un avenir commun on est dans
une crise de perspective une crise du de
la mise en commun et c'est ça
aujourd'hui l'enjeu pour les dirigeants
européens et nous on attend à ce que le
projet européen soit remis en selle en
lien avec la population il faut toutir
autrement il faut refaire autrement il
faut faire une Europe plus concrète pour
les gens parce que c'est ça qui est
important votre parti Europe Écologie
Les Verts votre formation est plutôt
divisée est-ce que la thématique de
l'Europe aussi peut vous permettre de
vous fédérer et d'avoir uni les
écologistes sont fondamentalement
européen et fédéraliste et donc nous on
pense qu'aujourd'hui la crise elle est
pas c'est pas une crise du trop d'Europe
mais c'est une crise de moins d'Europe
sur les questions sociales sur les
questions environnementales et donc
c'est ça le travail de refondation
aujourd'hui qui doit être l'actualité
des dirigeants européens et on a on aura
une élection européenne en 1900 en 2019
il faut profiter de cette élection pour
que ce soit une élection d'une
constituante qui construit véritablement
l'Europe des peuples on va quand même
s'arrêter un petit peu sur l'actualité
d'Europe Écologie parce que ces dé
visisions elles existent ces derniers
mois de nombreux élus ont quitté van le
groupe parlementaire a été dissous le
nombre d'adhérents aurait été aussi
divisé par de depuis 2013 aujourd'hui
vous seriez moins de 7000 adhérentss et
puis il y a l'a faire beauin aussi qui
va forcément laisser des traces votre
secrétairetion national David Corm va
devoir tout changer aujourd'hui il faut
tout revoir aussi aussi bien en Europe
que pour Europe Écologie d'abord Europe
Écologie a vécu une crise mais une crise
qui est globale pour les partis
politiques et pour les
représentants et les élus donc on l'a
vécu certes de manière plus profonde
c'est confrontter deux visions une
vision qui était plutôt pour revenir à
la base de l'accord qu'on avait avec le
parti socialist en 2012 et c'est ça qui
a engagé notre partenariat pour les
législatives et la création des deux
groupes parlementaires et des personnes
qui souhaitaient continuer même si au
niveau du fond et au niveau des projets
on se retrouvait pas de continuer à être
dans l'accompagnement et le partage des
responsa le Parti socialiste on est
plutôt en train de vivre une
clarification tous ceux qui ont souhaité
partir parce qu'ils étaient en des
acccords sans parti et maintenant on a
un défi de reconstruction et donc on a
eu un congrès récemment ligne
majoritaire s'est dégagé et je souhaite
beaucoup de courage et de chance à David
Corman pour ce travail de refondation du
parti et ça se fa en opposition avec la
politique qui est menée actuellement
parce que Europe Écologie Les Verts vous
vous soutenez globalement le mouvement
contre la loi travail vous soutenez les
grévistes la CGT mais c'est pas tant en
opposition que sur le projet écologiste
je pense que tous les écologistes
aujourd'hui dans le parti Europe
Écologie Les vert sont pour
l'indépendance du projet écologiste et
de son offre politique la question du
contrat et de l'Alliance elle se pose
dans un deuxème temps et comme tout
contrat on ne continue à le tenir que
parce que le partenaire avec qui on a
conclu le contrat le tient le problème
fondamentalement fondamental qu'on a
dans cette législature et je crois que
c'est le grand échec de la gauche
globalement nous on s'est présenté au
législative à partir d'un accord qu'on a
avec le Parti socialiste cet accord ne
s'est pas transformé en feuille de route
claire et concrète avec le président de
la République et dès le début du mandat
de François Hollande un certain nombre
de positions antiécolo ont vu le jour et
les engagements n'ont jamais été
donc la priorité c'est de reconstruire
d'abord un projet écologiste et une
offre politique écologiste et la
question des alliances elle doit venir
dans un second temps dans le cadre d'un
accord possible sur des questions de
fond concrètes qui interrogent les
citoyens la question de l'énergie de
l'autonomie énergétique la sortie du
nucléaire la question de l'agriculture
biologique la question de la précarité
énergétique pour les pour les
populations c'est sur ces sujets-l qu'il
faut revenir je pense que notre vie la
vie politique se Meur des accords de
tactique et d'appareil et donc il faut
revenir aux questions de fond et c'est
ce qu'on a commencé à faire il faut
clarifier son positionnement politique
aussi parce que vous parliez de ceux qui
étaient parti euh jean-vincan placé par
exemple ancien d'Europe Écologie qui est
aujourd'hui secrétaire d'État il a
déclaré qu'il ne voyait plus la
différence entre le parti gauche et
Europe Écologie Les Verts est-ce qu'il a
raison c'est c'est c'est c'est pas vrai
et c'est vrai que ce procès pour
gauchisme a souvent été utilisé comme un
prétexte de ceux qui sont parti moi j'ai
eu la chance et vous le savez de faire
une campagne auprès d'Emmanuel cos et
des écologistes euh en île- de- France
on éétait pas en alliance avec le Front
de gauche on était autonome on a fait
une campagne d'écologiste d'une écologie
politique affirmée et autonome au prier
tour et au deème tour il y a eu des
discussions entre la liste conduite par
Claude Bartelone la liste du Front de
Gauche et la nôre et on a pu fisionner
sur une base programmatique c'est ça
l'écologie que moi j'aime on affirme
quand il le faut le projet écologiste et
on construit des convergence pour
pouvoir construire des majorités et je
je crois que c'est cette ligne là qui
est devant nous h on va marquer une
pause on va parler de vous de votre
parcours je vous en prie passz en salle
on va parler aussi de ce mandat de
conseiller régional je vous en
[Musique]
prie le café politique aujourd'hui avec
Mounier Satouri conseiller régional
d'île-de-fance vous êtes responsable de
ce groupe écologiste vous êtes né en
1975 votre engagement politique débute
avec l'adolescence vous vivez au Maroc
avec votre famille et vous vous engagez
auprès de la jeunesse de l'USFP Parti de
Gauche qu'elle a été l'élément
déclencheur pour cet engagement à
l'époque c'est un engagement à gauche et
à l'adolescence c'est plutôt c'est
toujours un engagement pour les valeurs
humanistes les valeurs d'égalité et de
liberté mais c'est un engagement plutôt
fort et qui vous a causé du tort aussi
parce que lors d'une grève menée par des
étudiant vous êtes arrêté vous êtes jugé
pour trouble public et envoyé en prison
pour 4 semaines c'est ça pouz nous
raconter un peu plus ce ce moment on
imagine délicat et qui a dû forger
encore plus vos convictions politiques
alors c'est c'est drôle parce que la
manifest ation c'était samedi comme
j'étais un un jeune engagé je faisais
plutôt de ceux qui appelaient à ce que
la manifestation se passe dans de bonnes
conditions et que il n'y ait pas les
casses qui donc remettent en cause les
raisons légitimes de cette manifestation
le soir même alors je m'en souviens
comme c'était hier il y avait une pièce
de
théâtre qui se produisait dans la ville
une pièce de de Molière et donc en
rentrant de spectacle vers 11h le soir
mon frère aîné m'annonce que la police
était venue qu'il y avait une
convocation pour que que j' au
commissariat le lendemain et suis à ça 4
semaines de d'enfire à cet âge là de
procès et puis qui se termine par un
jugementfin une condamnation à de la
prise en Vic surcis pour trouble à
l'ordre public alors bien sûr à 15 ans
on le vit pas avec le recul qu'on peut
avoir plus tard mais en tout état de
cause sa Tacte a été l'élément
déclencheur qui a fait que mon papa a
fait appel au homo familial pour que je
vienne le rejoindre en France parce que
lui travaillait déjà pour en France et
il a fait venir toute la famille dans
les ivelines justement comment s'est
passé cette arrivée vous l'avez vécu
comme un un autre départ comme une
double sanction après déjà la
condamnation ou je l'ai vécu comme une
découverte parce que quand on est jeune
d'origine marocaine qu'on fréquente le
Centre culturel français qu'on étudie la
littérature française et qu'on connaît
un peu son histoire bah la France est la
patrie des droits de l'homme c'est la
patrie de l'émancipation c'est la patrie
de l'engagement politique et donc je vis
cette découverte comme belle expérience
je suis accueilli par l'école française
avec des profs engagés géniaux qui
m'accompagne en plus de ce qu'il devrait
faire pour que je récupère mon retard
sur la langue française et puis j'ai
fait mes études je m'y installe et donc
j'ai un rapport très très amoureux à la
République française et l'engagement
politique du coup est encore plus fort
et votre famille le comprend cet alors
d'abord il y a un paradoxe j'étais à 15
ans et demi moi quand je suis arrivé
j'étais surpris par par le peu
d'engagement politique des jeunes donc
je comprenais pas que le lycéen quand on
se voyait pour boire un café à côté de
je comprenais pas que ça parlait pas
politique Ava plus de liberté pour
exprimer juste et moi j'avais une double
diité c'est comme je maîtrisais pas
beaucoup la langue française j'avais du
mal à m'exprimer et à
participer aux discussions politiques et
donc en fait ça prend son sens au début
de la vie étudiante et c'est vrai que le
mouvement étudiant il y a plus de débat
il y a plus de il y a plus d'engagement
et donc la suite logique de de de mon
engagement à l'USFP c'est le parti
socialiste marocain en fait c'est l'un
socialiste des forces populaires c'est
j'adère au Parti socialiste au MGS et au
Parti socialiste jusqu'en 2001 où une
crise de perspective et de sens et la
prise en compte de la question
environnementale et de l'urgence
environnementale et climatique m'amène à
fréquenter les écolos et petit à petit à
me désengager du Parti socialiste il y a
la question du droit de vote des
étrangers aussi qui aussi pour votre
changement
principalement il y a la question du du
droit de vote à l'époque le projet du
candidat Jospin était en train de se
construire je crois que l'animatrice du
du projet c'était Martin auri et donc
sur la question du droit de vote des
étrangers qui était une promesse de
miteran bien plusut tôt était dire on va
pas mettre la question du droit de V des
étrangers dans le programme mais dès
qu'on sera élu on va on va l'appliquer
vous parliez de Johel Jospin justement
2001 c'est un moment particulier avec le
Front National qui se retrouve peu de
temps après au au second tour de
l'élection présidentielle vous le vivez
comment ce moment où vous vous changez
un peu de formation politique et ce qui
est en train d'arriver aux forces de
gauche j'ai rejoint les vers fin 2001
donc c'était un petit peu avant et
surtout avec l'analyse que
l'idéologie socialiste et et et la
limite de la question de la croissance
et du partage une fois qu'il y aura la
croissance on est dans la logique du
partage à mes yeux commence à prendre
ses limites parce que à l'époque moi qui
vivais en Bonlieu et qui travaillait
dans le champ de l'insertion
professionnelle en Bonlieu je commençais
déjà à me rendre compte que c'est pas
parce qu'il y avait la croissance et que
l'emploi revenait que si ce celles et
ceux qui ont étai le plus exclus
retrouvit le chemin de l'emploi et donc
la question du myth de la croissance qui
quand on la retrouve tout va bien parce
qu'on peut la partager ça prenait sa
limite et en fait l'échec euh de Lionel
Jospin qui ne va pas au 2è tour pour moi
confirme la limite de cette vision du
monde de cette vision binaire et donc
conforte h
l'engagementcolo et surtout l'engagement
que la prospérité en Occident en tout
cas ne viendrait pas seulement avec la
croissance et qu'il faut changer de
paradigme il faut d'abord se préoccuper
de l'avenir de nos enfants et préserver
cet avenir et partager les richesses
avec ou sans croissance et je crois
qu'aujourd'hui on est en plein dans ce
débat là il y a une vraie fracture
aujourd'hui entre vous et le Parti
socialiste je parle pas d'Europe
Écologie et du Parti socialiste mais je
parle vraiment de vous quel rapport vous
entretenez avec les socialistes vous qui
les avez côtoyé de prè puisque vous
étiez adhérant avant d'en partir euh
aujourd'hui les discussions sont faciles
à paiser vous comment vous jugez parti
socialist l'homme de gauche que je suis
au début de ce
mandat j'aurais pu entendre euh un
certain nombre de réunement économiques
même si je partage pas l'analyse
j'entendais la logique en disant il faut
les déficites il faut d'abord réduire
les déficites avant de faire le partage
des richesses et cetera ce qui a été
l'élément de
rupture déterminant c'est la question de
la déchance de la nationalité parce que
là on était sur des questions morales on
était sur des questions moral qu'on tous
les experts tous les spécialistes
disaient que la question deité ne
réglait rien à la question du terrorisme
à la question de la radicalisation et à
la question de de la crise sociétale
dans laquelle on vivait et que vous
aviez un président de la République un
Premier ministre qui brondissait ça
comme l'arme suprême qui allait régler
tous les problèmes pour moi c'était je
l'ai dit d'ailleurs un débat que j'ai eu
dans le montoi et c'était paradoxal je
me suis retrouvé à ce débat-là avec un
représentant de la droite Patrick
deidjon qui s'engageit contre la
déchéance et avec une députée locale
socialiste qui est venu au débat parce
que c'était compliqué à porter et et là
on était dans une rupture morale et je
crois que la gauche peut se permettre de
commettre un certain nombre d'erreurs et
le peuple de gauche peut lui pardonner
mais pas sur les questions morales pas
sur les questions qui font le fondement
de notre République de l'égalit
et de la fraternité plus globalement
votre regard sur ce quinquena avec
François Holland au plus bas dans les
sondages manuel Vals aussi un gros gachi
vous rendez compte que lorsqu'on a
réussi à virer Sarco en 2002 la gauche
et les écologistes avait tous les
pouvoirs on était majoritaire au Sénat
on était majoritaire dans la majorité
des départements et des communes la
quasittalité des région à l'Assemblée
nationale vous voyez l'opportunité de
transformation au profondeur de notre
société qui était entre nos mains et on
a on est passé à côté ils sont restés
dans le train et jamais ils se sont
arrêtés aucun arrêt n'a été l'occasion
de se poser et de dire on a une
opportunité historique et il faut pas la
gâcher donc un gros gâchi
qu'attendez-vous dEurope écologie les
ver c'est la question que nous sommes
allés poser dans les rues de
Saint-Quentin en evveline dans le
département je je vous laisse écouter
rien de particulier parce que ils
finissent par m'énerver il suppriment
tout on a plus le droit de rien et
franchement c'est plus la France quoi je
veux bien bien qu'on soit vert moi je
fais très attention à tous les produits
et cetera mais faut pas abuser non plus
malheureusement je trouve que là ils
perdent beaucoup de temps à se disputer
entre eux et du coup ça manque
d'efficacité quoi ils sont pas très
crédibles voilà ben faire appliquer les
les décisions prises à la COP 21 déjà
sassurz que c'est bien respecté lutter
continuer à lutter contre le gaz de
chiste contre les l'exploitation
complètement
délirante de de de de l'environnement
voilà qui passe aux actes
et puis qui mettent en place des choses
dans les villes c'est important par
exemple des villes comme comme Grenoble
ils ont mis des bacs
àfleurs ils font ils ont supprimé
certaines rues ils les ont mis piétones
et je pense que c'est vraiment très très
bien il y a de la déception des attentes
aussi oui d'abord il y a une remarque
globale que moi je partage et je vote
pour c'est la question des chamailleries
et donc moi je fais partie de ceux et
qui disent il y a une clarification ceux
qui étaient pas d'accord avec la ligne
globale sont partis et ceux qui restent
ça veut pas dire qu'on pense tous la
même chose parce qu'il y a des nuances
et on pourrait en parler maintenant il
faut arrêter il faut arrêter le bisb
interpersonnel et travailler sur le
projet sur le fond et sur le projet
écologiste qu'on veut porter pour la
société dans les villes dans les régions
et au niveau national ça moi j'adhère
complètement à cette critique et et je
votei sans aucune réticence et après il
y a le paradoxe écolo h vous voyez une
des des personnes dit il faut que les
écologistes continuent à lutter contre
le gaz de ch et cetera donc les écologes
qui sont là dans le contre et vous avez
une autre citoyenne qui dit
quel il faut pas que les écologistes ne
soi que dans le contre et qu'il faut que
les écologistes soient dans un système
d'adhésion et je crois que c'est ça le
paradoxe qu'on a face à nous et il il
faut qu'on puisse de manière beaucoup
plus importante décliner un projet
d'adhésion plus qu'un projet de critique
mais le projet écologiste part forcément
de la critique euh du de la société
libéral productiviste donc il faut qu'on
arrive à trouver l'équilibre par exemple
moi j'ai envie que les écologistes se
distinguent par la défense de
l'agriculture de proximité et de
l'agriculture biologique et pas par la
la lutte contre l'agriculture
productiviste qui pollue donc on a un un
effort de pédagogie c'est une façon de
faire passer le message il faut travire
il faut qu'on soit beaucoup plus positif
faut qu'on donne envie je suis persuadé
que le projet écologiste est un projet
qui protège qui donne envie et qui
répond au défis du 21e siècle à nous de
savoir l'exprimer et l'exprimer de
manière positive al justement pour
l'exprimer est-ce que participer à une
primère de la gauche ce serait pas une
bonne opportunité parce queeope écologie
les vert ne veut pas entendre de parler
de cette primaire de la gauche
he alors moi j'étais pour la primaire
j'étais de ce chez Europe Écologie Les
vert qui était pour la primaire pourquoi
parce que la primaire nous permettait de
clarifier un certain nombre de sujets
avec comme arbitre le peuple et en
démocratie c'est toujours bien de
prendre comme arbitre le peuple mais
sans que ça tombe dans l'utre soi et
donc l'idée de dire on veut une primaire
de toute la gauche c'est parce qu'on est
conscient qu'il y a un débat qui
traverse la gauche et qu'il y a
différents courants au sein de la gauche
et y compris au partis socialiste la
question n'est pas n'est tranché dans
aucun parti aujourd'hui au Front de
gauche entre les le canal historique
Parti communiste et les amis de
jean-lque Mélenchon il y a des
discussions et des nuances au sein du
Parti socialiste entre les frondeurs et
la lig Vals il y a des discussions et et
des et des divergences et donc quand je
fais partie de àev qui disent on veut
une primaire c'est pour que ce débat là
soit tranché de manière publique de
manière concrè et pas est-ce quecologie
peeven peuple et que le peuple soit soit
souverain et le tranche et que ça
permettait ça nous permettait de
décliner et de dérouler le projet
écologiste sans qu'onre dans l'entesin
et l'enfermement je ne pense pas
qu'aujourd'hui dans le cadre des
institutions de la 5e République que les
écologistes ils peuvent seul être
majoritaire dans les institutions et
changer le réel et je n'ai pas envie que
les écologistes attendent h la
révolution qui permet d'avoir les
leviers institutionnels pour changer le
réel et donc en attendant on est dans la
le dilemme de travailler avec un certain
nombre de partenaires à gauche mais
aussi bien le Parti socialiste et le
Parti communiste moi j'étais sur une
liste au deième tour avec les gens du
Front de gauche et du Parti socialiste
et on l'a fait sur la base d'un
programme et on a d'abord négocié sur le
programme avant de négocier les places
et donc il y a des logiques dans les 5e
républiques qui nous permettent pas
d'accéder au responsabilités pour
changer la réel et donc on doit gérer
cette cette double contrainte c'est
comment dès aujourd'hui répondre à
l'uran environnementale et l'ence
climatique tout en continuant à faire
progresser le projet écologiste pour
qu'il devienne de plus en plus
majoritaire donc pour les primaires vous
allez militer pour qu'il y ait des
primaires même si ça semble mal
engagé déjà pour qu'il y ait des des
primaires ouvertes à toute la gauche
mais vous le dites vous-même ça semble
mal parti et donc au cas où les
primaires de toute la gauche n'est pas
lieu HES de parce que com il dit les
primaires de ceux qui sont d'accord avec
le gouvernement j'ai pas cru comprendre
que toute la gauche soutenit le
gouvernement actuel donc on a cette
nuance et donc si cette primaire n'est
pas lieu je suis à ce moment-là pour
qu'on soutienne un candidat écolo avec
la candidature la plus parlante possible
pour
le moi clairement je suis pour une
candidature de Nicolas Hulot je l'étais
déjà à l'occasion des
précédentes présidentielles mais il n'a
pas gagné la primaire interne à ELV je
suis prêt à soutenir Nicolas ho bien sûr
on en revient justement à cette question
de vos engagements vous siégez à la
région Île-de-France depuis l'an dernier
vous découvrez aussi ce rôle d'opposant
après la victoire de de la droite et et
du centre avec Valérie pcrè avant de
parler des justement des nouvelles
décisions qui ont été prises par cette
nouvelle majorité un mot sur l'ancienne
majorité celle de Jean-Paul hchon où
vous avez siégé aussi elle a été décriée
il y a eu également des audits qui ont
été fait sur des dépenses qui étaient
pas toujours forcément justifiées il y a
eu beaucoup de critiques en fait sur sur
le le précédent mandat comment vous les
avez vécu il a pas eu d'audit il y a eu
des rapports commandés par la présidente
et des rapports commandé la présidente
qui sont adressés au Figaro avant d'être
adressés aux élus d'opposition et quand
les élus d'opposition l'exigent il
reçoivent une synthèse avant de recevoir
au final le le rapport dans sa globalité
bon donc vous contestez bien évidemment
que je le contexe et d'ailleurs soyez en
clair si Valérie pcrè avait trouvé dans
le bilan de jean-pauluchan des choses
répréhensibles elle serait allée devant
la justice donc c'est pas le cas Valérie
PCR a gagné les élections elle est en
droit de critiquer le bilan politique de
la mandature précédente moi j'ai le
droit et le devoir de le défendre j'ai
fait partie de cette majorité je
l'assume jusqu'au bout y compris sur ce
qu' aujourd'hui elle tente
de présenter comme euh le prétexte de
tous les ronimentss je parle du passe
Navigo à tarif unique les écologistes
ont porté au premier tour en 2010 le
passe à tarif unique ils l'ont défendu
en interne ils l'ont obtenu bout bout à
bout et on est fier et content
qu'aujourd'hui le Pass unique existe
parce que passter cet été parce que le
Pass unique est ce qui fait l'union et
ce qui rassemble le territoire
francilien et c'est ce qui permet de
sortir de cette injustice qui est plus
tu habites loin et et et moins tuas de
transport et plus tu les payes cher et
en fait Valérie PCR avait prévu de
mettre moins d'argent sur le transport
en commun pour une raison simple c'est
qu'elle a prévu de financer beaucoup
plus les routes et donc elle était dans
une dans une impasse financière par
rapport à sa propre politique et donc
elle a utilisé tous les leviers et tous
les mensonges pour pouvoir faire sa
politique de droite de financement des
routes au détriment des transports en
commun sur la question du Pass Navigo
pour finir sur ce point écouter ce micro
trottoir justement bah écoutez je trouve
que c'est dommage parce que bah ouais
ils ont bien baissé hein
puisqueeectivement ils ont fait
un un tout zone quoi tout dézoné et puis
bah là à nouveau augmentation
quand on les prend tout le temps savez
on est mé content faut le dire si c'est
pour apporter des financements
supplémentaire je TR que c'est une bonne
chose ou parce que bon le prix
honnêtement quand on compare par rapport
aux autres capitales dans le monde en
l'eope je trouve qu'on est pas très cher
finalement bah si c'est pour tenir les
RAM en bon état il y a pas de problème
quoi franchement si c'est pour avoir la
sécurité sur nos train je trouve ça que
c'est parfait c'est une bonne chose si
ça permet d'améliorer la qualité des
transports en commun si c'est juste une
une augmentation comme ça pour faire
payer plus cher notamment les plus
défavorisés je pense que c'est
complètement une connerie voilà vous
avez déjà largement réagi sur cette
question du du passe Navigo mais plus
plus globalement sur le le le mandat le
début de mandat de Valérie PCR les
décisions qui sont prises je pense au
test salivaire dans les lycées pour
lutter contre le cannabis je pense aussi
au à la fin des financements des
logements très sociaux dans les communes
qui ont déjà plus de 30 % de logements
sociaux vous en pensez quoi depuis
plusieurs mois que Valérie PCR la droite
des cette région on voit tous ceux qui
perdent les jeunes les euh bénéficiaires
ou les candidats pour le logement social
euh l'environnement on le dit pas assez
mais par exemple CR c'est sa majorité et
je suis déçu que Chantal joano
accompagnent cela ils arrêtent les
financements pour les emplois
d'insertion environnement h ils arrêtent
l'aide et réduisent de manière drastique
l'aide pour l'agriculture biologique
donc on commence déjà à voir ceux qui
perdent ceux qui perdent c'est
l'environnement c'est le transport en
commun euh c'est les associations c'est
l'action sociale c'est l'action de
prévention de proximité dans les
quartiers donc on voit ceux qui perdent
et pour l'instant on voit pas
complètement ce qui gagnent mais on
commence à deviner donc Valerie pcrè va
mettre en place en île-de-fance une
politique de droite classique d'aide aux
entreprises et malheureusement aux très
grandes entreprises et pas aux petites
entreprises qui font le quotidien et la
cohésion dans nos territoires j'ai derre
projet de droite j'ai une dernière
question à vous poser vous avez été
naturalisé en 2002 je rappelle que vous
êtes né au Maroc on l'a évoqué tout à
l'heure aujourd'hui dans un climat de
repli identitaire aussi vous qui avez
grandi dans deux pays comment vous vous
sentez quel message vous voulez faire
passer dire la vérité euh moi je suis
inquiet je sens effectivement ce repli
identitaire et et et et et je sens une
montée euh du je vais pas vous dire
racisme parce que ça serait facile de la
peur de l'autre et de tous les côtés
et c'est un grand danger pour notre
République l'arrière fond de cela c'est
évidemment la crise économique la crise
de perspective et et la crise de la mise
en commun qu'on a dans cette société et
donc je je le dis de manière détendu et
ça concerne toutes les familles
politiques et tous les partis politiques
républicains si on ne revitalise pas
notre démocratie si on les hommes
politiques ne reviennent pas à de la
politique concrète si on sort pas des
promesses qui ne sont jamais tenu si on
ne fait pas plus confiance dans le faire
ensemble avec les populations ça va
continuer à se crisper et ça peut
s'aggraver donc notre République notre
bien commun est aujourd'hui de mon point
de vue en danger et on doit tous s
mettre pour le sauver merci Sator
d'avoir participé à ce café politique
merci à
[Musique]
vous